[Music]
um let's just get right into the loss um
obviously Jordan love played a
unbelievable game um but at the end of
the day we were just outperformed out
schemed however you want to put it like
they had an answer for everything and
people saying well why a't you go to
linebacker cuz you know they said you
can stop the run well guess what the
packages are in for me to go to
linebacker there's multiple packages
multiple variations
but I can only play what it's called
what whatever they're calling whoever
Personnel they're putting on I'm not
putting out Personnel I'm not putting
out uh the Cs there nothing's coming
from me so you could put that and put
that wherever you want to be or wherever
you want to put it but they're not
coming from me the packages are in I've
even told multiple players coaches that
I'm very fine playing linebacker in
playoffs if that's what y'all want me to
do I just want to win and you can ask
any coach ask any player that it's a god
honest truth because obviously this is
not where I want to be sitting right now
speaking to you talking about what we're
doing at the Pro Bowl and that's just
the reality of it I do see a Super Bowl
in my future I want to be a Super Bowl
champion and it's very upsetting that
I'm even here having to even speak to
y'all and trying to say if I really care
about the game and if I'm showing up in
playoffs I challenge anyone to actually
go look at the game film and say did
Michel play his heart out in that game
and what more could I have done you know
and you you know it's sad man that you
lose the way you do especially at home
talking about how much we played at home
uh how much it stood for us to be at
home and to go out like that at home was
completely embarrassing and unacceptable
so you know I couldn't even look at that
loss or feel any type of way because of
how embarrassed I felt I felt you know
the utmost you know just man it was just
I say it it took me a while to even be
able to show my face in the public I
like disappeared like completely so you
know it it really showed to me that you
know um that you really see how much
people care about the game of football
and the culture and uh the people you
want around you when you say you want to
build a Super Bowl championship team and
the the truth about it you know and um
it sucks and you know you know sing sing
here and uh you know they talking about
we're going all in this year man that's
what I would hope for you know I'm 24
years old I've been in this league you
know three years and I kind of seen it
all and uh I hope that we go all in I
hope that we go out and get the players
that we're missing because we didn't do
that this year you know I hope that we
challenge ourselves become better and
become greater for
us